[Music]
hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website comm and today we're going
to be studying the alaska trap which
comes from the queen's gambit opening
line from white and The Alibi encounter
gained it from black so we're gonna be
looking at it from blacks point of view
and why it starts out with pawn to d4 we
respond pawn d5 and white offers up the
Queens gambit with pawn to c4 and if
you're like me and you play black at any
amount of time you're going to see this
quite often so I highly recommend
getting to know the alb on counter game
it which is pawn to e5 it's a great play
white players really don't know how to
play it very often play against it and a
lot of times you'll see a lot of bad
moves and especially if you have someone
that hasn't seen it very often you may
be able to use the Alaska trap that
we're going to be going over today so
play can resume with the main line and
that is pawn captures 'if I've and
blacks going to respond with pawn to d4
putting more pressure on white here
white can no longer develop his knight
to the C 3 squared which he'd really
like to this is going to be a pain in
the side of white for a while he's gonna
have to do something about off so we can
bring our knight to c6 add another
defender so from here you may see the
the move which is going to be a mistake
and that is pawn to e3 now even if white
does not make this mistake black still
has a lot of good gameplay so don't feel
that you know if they don't do this and
they don't fall into the trap that
you're just completely lost you're
actually not you can have a lot of good
counter counter gameplay in the Albine
counter game it so from here why it is
basically
hoping that we're going to just capture
and then they can come down capture our
queen and when we recapture we can no
longer castle but we're not going to do
that we're continue with the Alaska
trapline and that is simply bringing our
Bishop to b4 and checking the White King
now from here you'll see a lot of times
white bring his Bishop to d2 obviously
protecting his king and at the same time
attacking the the bishop on d4 now from
here what black is simply going to
capture on e3 white can not recapture on
e3 because the bishop here on b4 would
be attacking the king but from here
white can make the big mistake of taking
our Bishop on before thinking he can
freely get even more material advantage
but he's going to be mistakenly wrong
from here black can continue to capture
on f2 now white cannot recapture on f2
because we can simply come in and take
the Queen on d1 obviously that would be
a lost position for white so from here
obviously he can't move to d2 because
our queen tzer's who's gonna move to e
to and from here we're simply going to
move to g1 and we're going to under
promote to a knight checking the king
and obviously you may be looking at this
rook here but white cannot take this on
to you one we can but then we can simply
come in to g4 with our Bishop and we're
gonna win the Queen so that's not
recommended so from here what you'll see
is the King move to e 1 and from here we
can simply move our Queen to h4 now why
would really like to just simply bring
his pawn to g3 but then we can just come
into a four and fork the rook on h1
check on check to the King on e 1 so
instead you'll see
the king basically moved to d2 now from
here black can simply move Knight to c6
and this is just a devastating move for
black eventually we're going to bring
our Bishop into the action and then we
can Castle queenside and the white king
is just stuck out in the middle and he's
gonna have a hard time getting away and
at the same time we're gonna be applying
lots of pressure on all his pieces
obviously right now we're applying
pressure on the bishop on before once
you bring our piece out we're going to
be attacking the Queen on d1 once we
castle we're going to be attacking the
King
so why it's gonna be running all over
the board we're gonna have all the
momentum and we're just going to be
attacking until we win the game and it
should be a pretty easy win for black so
this is the last row trap if you do pay
play the Alpine counter gambit you may
come across this quite often so play
with it experiment see how you guys like
it and let me know thanks for watching
the video if you guys have not
subscribed to the videos please go ahead
and do that we got a lot of great stuff
coming out and I will see you guys next
video thanks